when facing a threat to our survival
our most primal response is to fight or
flight
but how do you fight when the threat is
invisible and where do you flee
when there is no planet b
the eu has chosen to fight on behalf of
all its citizens
with the socialists and democrats in the
front line
together we are ready to battle for a 60
reduction in carbon emissions by 2030
and get this target down on paper in
europe's
first ever climate lore it may have been
called a man on the moon moment
but let's face it the apollo mission was
a walk in the park
compared to the challenges facing the
world today
as the eu aims to become the first
climate neutral continent by 2050
the s d group wants to ensure that each
and every member state
reaches carbon neutrality and we must
achieve this
without making other parts of the world
pollute for our consumption
[Music]
carbon neutrality requires a balance
between emitting
and absorbing carbon from the atmosphere
in order to achieve net zero emissions
all greenhouse gas emissions have to be
counter balanced
by equivalent sequestration in carbon
sinks
the main natural carbon sinks are soils
forests and oceans but our emission
levels are currently way above what
these can absorb
and no technology is able to remove
carbon from the atmosphere
on the necessary scale
we're also constantly losing and
damaging our carbon sinks
we can try to fight back with emissions
trading and offsetting but it won't be
enough
[Music]
in order to save our future there's no
alternative
but to drastically reduce our emissions
[Music]
but it will take more than individual
actions to address climate change
youth has shown us the way a way towards
a greener future
better health and a fairer economy
they have challenged the political world
to tackle climate change
to improve air quality to provide
greener jobs
it is now down to member states to act
and transform this challenge into
opportunities for all
we as the socialists and democrats
pledge to hold them accountable
there is nowhere to flee
we need everyone to step up
make a giant leap for mankind